and that's more important than my own
personal
ambition all right so Chris Christie the
former Governor of New Jersey who also
ran for president in 2016 uh he is
announcing that he is suspending his
campaign basically that means he is out
of the GOP Primary race he made this
announcement in New Hampshire at a
scheduled Town Hall this news was sort
of percolating throughout the afternoon
he made it official just now we'll do a
quick round before we get on to our
other subjects Greg that was quite a
windup oh man you know um he knew Trump
would be the
nominee but he felt that he had to make
the case that he shouldn't well get in
line that's not necessary you have the
media doing that you got the government
doing that you have tech companies doing
that he was like it was so redundant you
didn't need that candidate in there I
think you know he's a he's a good guy
likable guy very uh uh intelligent but
the analogy for me is a hocky goon you
know you put a you put a guy out in the
ice to take out the best player that's
what it was and so and that is that part
of the race at least is over now Jesse
what do you make of all of it I agree I
mean I like the guy personally I used to
like when he used to tee off people on
town halls and but he killed himself
with the bridge and the hug and he ran
out of money let's be honest he ran out
of money and I don't like how he says
that I'm here to tell the truth that's
basically saying 75 million Americans
don't want to hear the truth they just
don't want to hear your opinion about
Donald Trump okay he had a lot of bad
negative things to say about Donald
Trump you can hear that from the Biden
campaign we don't need to hear that from
a republican so good luck Chris
Christie it's been real judge I don't
think he ran out of money he ran out of
possibility he ran out of Runway because
he wasn't going any the polling was just
completely stuck he had about 12% in New
Hampshire uh only about 3% in Iowa that
never changed the 12% he moved up a
little bit but I think he had to read
the writing on the wall like this is not
happening for me this time around yeah
it wasn't happening for him it isn't
happening for him uh it was almost an
embarrassment but but I have to tell you
I was offended by that I mean clearly he
is you know he's auditioning for some
kind of uh you know contributorship or
something on another Channel but at the
same time he says you know I knew last
time he was going to win Donald Trump
and that's why I supported him
explaining why there is so much um he
has so much malevolence toward him I
mean his whole campaign was about
divisiveness and anger every time he
open his mouth there would be another
thing about Donald Trump nothing about
Joe Biden okay the person that he hated
was Donald Trump he was in this race to
attack Don Donald Trump and he's
actually in his last speech here he's
patting himself on the back for being a
great leader and I'm here to tell you
the truth and you need me to tell you
the truth no I don't the American people
don't and as you said you know 73 people
they 73 million people can figure out
what they think is the truth and you
know he even talks about hostages and
Israel I mean you know just cut it out
go away and we'll be happier okay um
Jessica there is still somebody in the
race that is not named Trump Haley or D
santis it's ASA Hutcherson he's still in
he's still in yeah he haven't had a
speech from his little heart out um
obviously there was no anti-trump Lane
at this level there's the alternative to
Trump Lane which is where Nikki Haley is
and Chris anuno the governor of New
Hampshire has been pushing for Chris
Christie to drop out because when their
powers combine they get over 50% so if
Chris Christie's voters go with the
Haley voters and that becomes the
anti-trump block then maybe she has a
chance at beating him in no Hampshire
only um I still don't think that it
happens I think that Trump is too
powerful at this point and and has too
much of a apparently Chris Christie was
on a hot mic saying something very
similar right before that has always
been the problem for me because I was
saying I love what Chris Christie is
saying but I'm a Democrat I admire
anybody who throws her hat in the ring I
will never ever do it I I would not be
able to and his wife Mary Pat was there
um so that and that for Chris Christie
and I think it ends that for us as well
we will be right back no no no let's
hear more hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else